de grandes confrontations entre les
régimes autoritaires et les régimes
démocratiques on va en parler ce soir
erdoine la fin du nerf point
d'interrogation bien sûr grand débat
dans un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau avant de retrouver nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu
vous me suivez Dominique Simoneau c'est
vert c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est une élection pour les Turcs mais
c'est aussi un enjeu planétaire qui va
se jouer ce dimanche 64 millions
d'électeurs appelés aux urnes et pour la
première fois erdohann l'un des symboles
des régimes autocratiques au pouvoir qui
tient la Turquie d'une main de fer et
fragilisée alors pour comprendre ce soir
ce point de bascule mes invités baryriam
baldjeb bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes chercheur aux séries de Sciences Po
le centre de recherche internationale
bonsoir Unal et bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes économiste aux cépi le Centre
d'études de prospective et d'information
internationales enfin bonsoir Vincent
Vincent Huger grand reporter chroniqueur
international dans cette émission
spécialiste des questions géopolitiques
Dominique Simoneau c'est pas votre sujet
la Turquie mais vous connaissez les
détentions des voilà des prisonniers en
Turquie on en dira un mot tout à l'heure
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à intervenir à
interroger nos invités je vous donne la
parole mais on va planter le décor comme
chaque soir avec la mi Stéphane
blackovski pourquoi
erdohann cette fois peut perdre il a
deux secondes black o top chrono
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors l'enjeu de cette
élection alors c'est parti pour 200
secondes donc erdan est au pouvoir en
Turquie depuis 20 ans d'abord disant
comme premier ministre puis 10 ans comme
président et désormais il a quasiment
les pleins pouvoirs et pourtant pourtant
on se demande si dimanche soir R21 sera
toujours au pouvoir à l'issue des
élections donc présidentielles et
législatives donc ils tirent deux gros
boulets le premier boulet c'est le
séisme du mois de février qui l'a très
mal géré en tant que chef d'État au
point que lui le leader infaillible
voyez a dû présenter ses excuses
demandées pardon parce que les secours
étaient très mal organisés ça aussi
permis de révéler que beaucoup de
bâtiments étaient mal construits
peut-être pour ça aussi qui sont
écroulés en si grand nombre à cause de
la corruption qui fragilise le BTP dans
ce pays le deuxième boulet c'est lié à
la crise économique alors on se plaint
souvent en France de l'inflation qui
rend notre pouvoir d'achat les fins de
mois difficiles regardez où on en est en
Turquie il y a eu un que délirant de 85%
d'inflation l'été dernier actuellement
on en est encore au-dessus de 40% et
d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est un lien
c'est pas impossible mais quand il a
commencé son nouveau mandat il a nommé
comme ministre de l'Économie son gendre
ceci ayant peut-être un rapport avec
cela mais ça c'est le système
Erdogan c'est ce qui est devenu la
Turquie un pays où les postes importants
sont pas occupés par des gens compétents
mais par des gens qui sont complètement
dévoués à hors de gamme mais au-delà de
ça ce qui fragilise la candidature c'est
que pour la première fois le position
qui est des très divisé a réussi à se
réunir alors pas très spectaculaire on
appelle ça la table des 6 donc c'est
très hétéroclite il y a un
social-démocrate une nationalité extrême
droite un islamiste son accord sur rien
sauf sur une chose il faut chasser
erdoğan du pouvoir et voilà le leader
qui se sont choisis s'appelle Kemal
kilich daroglou donc vous voyez que
c'est pas du tout de sierdon pas du tout
le style gros dur il a joué au contraire
le petit cœur comme signe de ralliement
un souci d'apaisement on a un carnet et
langue d'ATT aque de derdoine c'est
parce que kylise daroglou et euh allez-y
donc difficile à expliquer ce que c'est
en gros un islam qui ressemble pas
tellement à l'islam dans le fond puisque
les femmes ont droit de ne pas être
voilées on a le droit de boire de
l'alcool et c'est l'angle d'attaque qui
a choisi air de one pour attaquer son
rival on écoute
monsieur Kemal buvez autant que vous
voulez vous pouvez boire un fût de bière
entier même cela ne vous rendra pas
meilleur mature qui ne donnera jamais la
parole en alcoolique et un ivrogne
oui forcément si le erdon était battu
après un coup pareil ça serait pas
forcément une mauvaise nouvelle pour
l'Europe vous savez bien que il est
extrêmement virulent contre nous je vous
rappelle que il a quasiment traité le
président Macron de cinglé et il a
carrément traité
Angela Merkel de nazi donc l'idée d'un
changement ce serait plutôt bienvenu
pour les démocraties finales il y a deux
sujets sur lesquels les positions de la
Turquie pourraient peut-être évoluer par
exemple il y a des manœuvres militaires
qui sont pleines de tension avec la
graisse qui est un pays membres de l'UE
peut-être qu'un changement pourrait
apaiser ce côté-là et puis ce qui
préoccupe encore plus c'est la proximité
d'erdon avec Poutine à qui il a acheté
des missiles alors que la Turquie fait
partie de l'OTAN mais dimanche il y a
des élections donc vous êtes là pour
débattre est-ce que ça peut changer ou
pas moi j'ai envie de rêver peut-être
une Turquie démocratique se prépare
peut-être même que elle va revenir dans
l'Europe on sait pas espérons-le en tous
les cas merci beaucoup Stéphane je vais
vous donner la parole dans un tout petit
instant mais je vous propose d'abord de
prendre la température direction
Istanbul où nous attend Ludovic de
Foucault bonsoir Ludovic vous êtes
correspondant en Turquie pour France 24
quelle est l'atmosphère de à deux jours
du scrutin les derniers sondages
donnent-ils toujours l'opposant à
Erdogan en tête
bonjour bonjour à tous écouter
l'atmosphère est assez chargé d'ailleurs
vous voyez le ciel d'Istanbul et très
couvert et très bas aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de sentiments qui se bousculent
la tente bien sûr l'anticipation un peu
de confusion un peu d'inquiétude aussi
et puis aussi un peu d'excitation il
faut se mettre à la place des Turcs pour
la première fois depuis qu'il dirige ce
pays depuis 21 ans reggian taille perd
Doha n'a jamais été aussi proche de la
sortie donc il y a effectivement un peu
d'électricité dans l'air oui les
derniers sondages continuent de montrer
que le candidat de l'opposition que
malkeus Zalando a une légère avance et
ce sont des sondages qui ont été publiés
en plus avant que un troisième petit
candidat se retire de la course hier moi
mg qui lui-même issu du CHP le plus
grand parti de l'opposition
la plus grande partie ou une bonne
partie de ces votes devraient
normalement ou naturellement se reporter
sur l'opposition donc ici en Turquie
il y a de plus nombre de plus en plus de
gens qui évoquent maintenant ouvertement
l'hypothèse crédible d'une victoire de
l'opposition dès le premier tour dès ce
dimanche alors un mot rapide sur la
campagne comment s'est-elle déroulée
est-ce qu'elle était totalement
déséquilibrée d'un point de vue
médiatique en faveur d'erdohann
oui évidemment 90% des médias sont
contrôlés ici par des groupes proches du
pouvoir l'OCDE a publié un rapport
récent sur cette question qui montrait
que ce taux était de tous les pays de
l'OCDE le plus important en Turquie
après ça ne veut pas dire que
l'opposition n'a pas ses propres moyens
de communication ses propres chaînes ses
propres canaux mais qui sont là aussi
elle-même assez partisanes donc on est
dans une situation où chaque camp ne
parle qu'à sa base et pas à celle des
autres donc ça renforce encore un peu la
polarisation qui caractérise la société
turque et c'est justement ce contre quoi
se bat l'opposition au niveau des médias
publics je vais vous donner un chiffre
qui a été communiqué par un membre de
hertux c'est l'équivalent de l'art comme
français la Haute Autorité des
régulations des médias il a calculé que
sur le mois d'avril et sur la chaîne
Territet aber donc ça serait
l'équivalent de France Info si vous
voulez une chaîne d'actu publique en
continu il y a eu 32 heures de temps de
parole pour la caper de Anne 32 minutes
pour l'opposition alors évidemment il y
a énormément
d'inquiétudes et d'interrogations sur le
jour du scrutin le tremblement de terre
a fait des des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de victimes certaines villes
ont été rasées des habitants ont été
déplacés est-ce que ces habitants là
vont-ils pouvoir voter normalement
normalement non parce que rien n'est
normal dans ces régions j'en reviens
d'ailleurs on y était encore la semaine
dernière la plupart des des écoles là où
on vote normalement sont détruites donc
il faut installer des nouveaux bureaux
de vote il faut aussi faire revenir des
centaines de milliers peut-être des
millions de gens qui ont fait voilà
cette migration intérieure pour aller
s'installer dans d'autres régions sans
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales de
leur nouvelle lieux de résidence donc il
faut organiser ses convois on voit que
c'est plus facile parfois pour ceux qui
vont voter dans des endroits qui sont
plutôt favorables à au gouvernement donc
l'opposition elle aussi s'investit pour
organiser tous ces convois donc
effectivement il y a une grande question
il faudra regarder ça de près au niveau
de l'organisation du scrutin dans ces
régions sinistrées
que le pouvoir fasse voter les morts
est-ce que c'est possible
c'est ce que c'est possible non je veux
dire en principe puisque la loi
évidemment l'interdit après quand on va
dans le Sud notamment dans les régions
comme celle du Hatay qui est favorable à
l'opposition c'est ce qu'on entend
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont dit ça ils vont faire voter les
morts parce qu'on est dans une situation
il y a énormément de gens dont on ignore
le nombre qui sont toujours porté
disparus qui ne sont donc pas
comptabilisés dans le bilan des victimes
là on est à 55000 morts je crois et en
revanche les bulletins de vote leurs
cartes des lecteurs pardon ont été si
vous voulez imprimer donc il y a
effectivement des gens qui craignent que
des que des que des fraudes de cette
nature aient lieu et on dit beaucoup je
crois cette phrase on sait comment les
Turcs vont voter on ne sait pas qui va
gagner l'élection est-ce que vous pensez
c'est ma dernière question Ludovic car
Dogan en cas de défaite accepte le
verdict des ions
je pense que le vote c'est quelque chose
de très important en Turquie il y a qu'à
voir le nombre de gens qui se sont
portés volontaires pour être
observateurs et pour justement s'assurer
que le vote se déroule dans de bonnes
conditions on n'est pas en Russie ici et
c'est très difficile de ne c'est même
impossible je pense pour Air Dean de ne
pas reconnaître le résultat du scrutin
si celui-ci est sans appel je crois que
il le sait s'il perd il perdra il y a
bien sûr des craintes d'éruption de
violence mais on parle peut-être plutôt
où on craint des cas isolées
l'opposition donne même des instructions
assez partisans en disant restez chez
vous n'allez pas dans des endroits qui
sont acquis au gouvernement préparer une
lampe de poche au cas où l'électricité
est coupée préparer un chargeur au cas
où il y a plus d'électricité voilà pour
votre téléphone utilisez un VPN pour
contourner les interdictions ou les ou
les les les annulations enfin
l'interdiction d'accès Internet voilà
donc il y a des il y a des craintes mais
au niveau de la de l'alternance si R2 on
perd il perdra aussi infiniment pour
voilà cette température prise à Istanbul
à 48 heures du scrutin merci Ludovic de
Foucault c'est un choix de civilisation
là qui attend les Turcs qu'on peut on
peut lire ça comment vous définiriez
l'enjeu il y a une tribune dans Le
Figaro de Nicolas bavray qui dit que
c'est comme si on était à la veille de
1933 en Turquie que les enjeux sont très
clairement la liberté ou la tyrannie
alors je dirais pas jusque là il y a un
enjeu considérable en Turquie mais je
dirais que l'enjeu il se faut qu'elle
est surtout sur la personnalité sur le
style de pouvoir du aldoine sur les
grandes sociétés qui d'habitude diviser
les Turcs le rapport à l'islam laïcité
les sujets qui divisent la Turquie le
clivage ethnique confessionnel je pense
que là-dessus globalement ça se passe
plutôt bien d'ailleurs le candidat en
face de erdouane c'est quand même un
analyse une première ça c'est plutôt je
pense que ces dernières années surtout
la deuxième décennie de pouvoir dial
douane qui a été particulièrement agité
violente avec beaucoup de tensions
politiques beaucoup de crispations et ça
les trucs qu'il voudrait que ça change
il voudrait que ça change et aussi une
motivation qui est beaucoup primordiale
pour eux il me semble c'est surtout les
considérations économiques parce que ces
deux dernières années il y a une
inflation assez galopante lui vous dites
sur KBC et surtout ce qui faisait la
postérieuse c'est qu'en fait auparavant
il a porté une croissance économique il
a été à l'origine aussi d'une création
d'une classe moyenne turque qui a fait
la force de son pouvoir or tout ça il ne
l'a plus la prospérité technique qui
nous l'a plu et les Turquie voudrait
qu'il y ait un retour de ce pouvoir de
d'achat qui est important et aussi moins
de tension moins de crispation moins de
clivage et ça c'est quelque chose qui
compte beaucoup pour les cures c'est
pour ça que ils ont le sentiment que le
clivage le style de clause jaloux passe
mieux parce qu'il y a moins de tension
alors donc dénigenal c'est c'est pas
forcément aussi binaire que ça extension
ou régression de l'autoritarisme pour
les Turcs c'est vraiment la situation
économique la paupérisation des Turcs
qui font qu'ils ont envie de tourner la
page aujourd'hui ils ont envie de
tourner les pages pour les raisons
économiques sans doute pas pour des
raisons civilisationnelles
mais surtout en dehors même de
l'économie pour des raisons de régime
politique pour un fonctionnement avec
des institutions
les institutions de régulation
qui fonctionne correctement c'est quand
on prend par exemple c'est très pâles
l'exemple de du double tremblement de
terre qui a frappé la Turquie c'est
flagrant ce gouvernement s'est vanter
d'avoir un une industrie de construction
très importante
compétitive et qui a sillonné l'ensemble
du pays mais résultat des courses
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu les fondations
n'avaient pas été fait correctement
c'était installé sur des failles et les
autorités qui devaient être responsables
pour secourir les gens ils étaient
complètement incompétents ils étaient
pas là pendant trois jours ils les ont
resté la faillite aussi alors
qui veut tourner la page est-ce que
c'est tout le pays est-ce que c'est les
urbains est-ce que c'est les plus jeunes
ce qui a un profil sociologique de celui
qui veut vraiment en finir avec le
système Erwan ou pas mise au pas toute
leur propagande qu'il faut beaucoup
évidemment la perception des Turcs c'est
quand c'est plutôt des villes mais il
faut dire que la Turquie est énormement
urbanisée maintenant il y a très peu de
monde finalement qui vit dans les
campagnes les personnes qui vont
emporter la personne dans la
présidentielle qui va importer le vote
des grandes villes il va importer les
présidentielles Vincent on a vu RDM
crier au terrorisme au complot LGBT
contre lui on sent bien qu'il est il est
fragilisé malgré on a vu les centaines
de milliers de supporters dans ces
meetings c'est quoi le régime
précisément selon vous comment vous
pouvez le qualifier on parle
d'autoritarisme d'autocratie certains
même dictatures
si les mots ont un sens on peut dire que
c'est un régime autoritaire
d'inspiration islamo conservatrices
c'est vraiment la matrice idéologique de
l'accapé donc le parti de douane le vrai
signal d'alarme a commencé à retentirer
l'actuellement pour lui dès 2019 on
évoquait l'importance à l'instant des
grandes villes lorsque deux villes les
principales
Istanbul et en carats sont tombés dans
l'escarcelle de l'opposition et
d'ailleurs il se trouve que donc Kemal
qui lise daroulou donc son rival qui est
pour le moment soyons prudents mais
favoris regard des derniers
à d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il ferait
des maires des aides élus à cette
occasion des vice-présidents sur
l'institution si on s'en tient au credo
qui est celui donc de killus darolu lui
estime que la Turquie est allée trop
loin et c'est une manière de répondre à
votre question d'aller trop loin dans
présidentialisation du régime et c'est
vrai que il y a eu une réforme
constitutionnelle qui permet à erdoğan
de confisquer la qualité des leviers de
l'exécutif il y a plus de Premier
ministre et ce que dit sorival c'est que
s'il parvient au pouvoir il va en
quelque sorte rétablir un équilibre des
pouvoirs qui a de fait disparu et puis
un dernier point également Ludovic de
Foucault faisait un peu la typologie des
enjeux électoraux moi j'ajoute deux
éléments qui sont aussi des éléments
d'incertitude le vote des Turcs de
l'extérieur près de 3 millions et demi
d'inscrits ça veut pas dire de votants
vous avez voté tous les deux oui c'est
le précise puisque les Turcs à
l'étranger ont voté avant le scrutin 400
000 en France et d'ailleurs c'était un
des indices de la fébrilité du pouvoir
vous avez eu des bagarres homériques
Amsterdam il y a eu de fortes tensions à
Lyon à Marseille etc avec des proser
Dean qui ont harcelé et parfois agressés
des électeurs suspectés d'être à
disposition et puis il y a une deuxième
grande question quel sera le vote de la
communauté kurda c'est pas homogène ne
soyons pas essentialiste c'est bien plus
compliqué que ça mais il n'empêche que
je me souviens parce que je suis allé
reportages à plusieurs reprises pour
L'Express à l'époque au début de l'ère
de Anne il avait une certaine forme de
popularité chez les Kurdes puisqu'il
avait donné des dégages d'ouverture par
rapport par exemple la liberté
éducatives linguistique et culturelles
ensuite ça s'est gâté donc il y a une
rupture avec les Kurdes évidemment pour
bien comprendre qui est le système
politique vous avez peut-être vu la une
du point budget
Erdogan l'autre Poutine vous êtes
d'accord avec cette comparaison là non
pourquoi il faut pas non plus exagérer
je pense que ça a été dit par mes
collègues aussi c'est que la Turquie
n'est pas la Russie il y a quand même
une tradition de respect d'énormes
démocratique il y a quand même une
tradition du respect de la légitimité
des urnes et je pense que là dessus même
si elle donnait depuis quelques années
dans une dérive autoritaire on est en
Turquie et Ludovic a dit tout à l'heure
c'est qu'en fait il y a quand même
respect des urnes de la légitime et je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse comparer il y
a une espèce d'exagération
mais effectivement je pense que la
dériveur était en Turquie il faut aussi
mettre les choses dans leur contexte
elle a aussi commencé émergé je pense
qu'il y a deux ailes le premier album il
est plutôt libéral ouvert quand il
arrive au pouvoir quand vous dites le
premier c'est jusqu'au coup d'État de
en 2007 2008 il est connu pour avoir
réformé le pays démocratisé il avait une
excellente réputation d'Occident il
était pro européen il a changé le code
pénal il a aboli la peine de mort si
ensuite c'est qu'on était pas voilà le
grand sultan le représentant
2013 ou 2011 aussi le contexte syrien
c'est aussi le coup d'état manqué contre
lui en 2016
il devient totalement paranoïaque il y a
ce coup d'état manqué contre lui il est
purge commence dans le pays c'est
vraiment à basculement Turquie
c'est vrai mais c'est pas il devient pas
paranoïaque du jour au lendemain en
réalité et il est pas très étonné de ce
qui arrive parce que
ils sont déjà brouillés avec
qui était quand même son allié au
pouvoir et il a mis dans à la tête de
beaucoup d'institutions dans les
fonctions
régaliens de l'État c'est au ministère
de la Justice ministère de l'Éducation
l'armée des guilinistes
et les ghulinistes pour ceux qui voilà
nous suivent c'était Guylène celui c'est
un prédicateur voilà c'est vrai qu'il
était à l'origine de l'attentative
avec raison d'être à l'origine de
l'attentat beaucoup d'État du coup
pardon pardonnez-moi je vous ai induit
en erreur voilà mais toi n'était préparé
à cela depuis déjà
2011-2012 il y avait une mésentente
entre eux
que les peaux avaient été coupés et donc
arrive c'est tentative en 2016 peut-être
qu'il a eu peur à edwan mais surtout il
en a profité parce que à cette époque il
avait été élu pour la première fois
c'était pas le peuple qui est Élisée le
président et c'est lui en 2014 qui avait
été élu président au lieu d'être Premier
ministre mais c'était un président qui
n'avait pas de pouvoir exécutif c'était
du coup qu'est-ce qu'il faisait et ben
il ramassait les enfin autour du lui il
a invité tous les mers les mers du
village les maires de vie il s'adressait
au peuple c'est là qu'il a commencé à
être populiste parce que elle donne est
une bête politique qui veut le pouvoir
effectivement on peut pas dire que la
Turquie et la Russie mais elle doit
pourraient devenir comme la poutine si
la nature a criminelle était comme la
Russie donc je veux dire que la Turquie
a une régime total
c'est un pays qui a eu des institutions
même à l'époque de l'Empire ottoman il y
avait des institutions avant
l'effondrement qui fonctionnait
correctement là maintenant c'est ça le
choix c'est pas un choix civilisationnel
c'est le choix de fonctionnement d'un
pays les hommes peuvent se ressembler
les uns les autres l'important c'est le
pays avec ces structures fondamentales
voilà c'est ça qui différencie la Russie
de la Turquie Vincent j'estime moi aussi
que l'analogie
erdoine Poutine est outrancière comme
Bayram valjeu par exemple pourquoi parce
que s'il y a un point commun entre les
deux personnages c'est qu'ils sont l'un
et l'autre les héritiers meurtries d'une
splendeur révolue il y a cher de Anne
comme chez Poutine et peut-être
d'ailleurs chez les dirigeants iraniens
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce que fut
l'empire perse une sorte de volonté de
restaurer de rétablir l'aura et la
puissance de ce que fut l'Empire ottoman
l'Empire russe etc et il y a chez l'un
et l'autre quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre du messianisme on l'a vu
d'ailleurs en Russie avec le glissement
vers une rhétorique plus religieuse que
politique récemment dire qu'ils sont
investis d'une mission qui est celle de
rétablir ce que l'histoire a injustement
détruit sur leur justement ce Messie la
dimension religieuse
Erdogan le nouveau sultan leader du
monde sunnite musulman ça bascule quand
ça vient d'où ça
je dirais que ça vient en fait elle doit
emprunter une voix autoritaire à partir
du moment ils sont en faiblesse ça aussi
c'est à dire que c'est il y a le premier
donc j'ai dit tout à l'heure il était
plutôt européen libéral les printemps
arabe la première place du printemps
arabe on est content parce qu'on
considère que la Turquie le modèle peut
être un modèle il faut pas l'oublier
parce que c'est un pays qui a conçu
consulat islam et démocratie il n'y a
que pendant un certain temps ensuite
quand les printemps arabes se
transforment malheureusement en hiver
j'étais beaucoup plus triste c'est là
aussi que les problèmes sécurité
d'instabilité
deviennent considérable au Moyen-Orient
et c'est à partir de là en fait que je
dirais que c'est aussi la crise sérine
qui va happer la Turquie avec toute
l'équipe c'est un instrument pour lui au
service de son pouvoir
il est il est plutôt il a mis
excusez-moi l'expression de l'eau dans
120 quand elle arrive au pouvoir de son
rapport à l'islam si ensuite au bout
d'un certain moment quand ils sont
beaucoup plus faibles il va s'empare de
l'islam mais à l'heure sa politique elle
n'est pas islamiste elle est beaucoup
plus pragmatique en fonction du moment
en fonction des besoins du moment il va
il a fait construire
l'idéologie de eldouane en fait elle est
pragmatique en fonction du besoin du
moment il va s'emparer d'une île de J
d'une idéologie ou d'une autre et à
l'heure actuelle il a recherche d'une
autre parce qu'il a perdu tous ses
alliés il cherche la prochaine on sait
pas si pour la trouver ou pas et on
parlait du régime autoritaire Dominique
on sait qu'en gros tous les opposants
les journalistes les militants les
universitaires vont en prison c'est quoi
la présomption turque
mais quand à vous écouter je me disais
quand je pense qu'il y a des gens qui
pensent que ici en France on n'est plus
en démocratie c'est quand même
je dis Parisi mais c'est tragique
comique parce que on vit que on a
beaucoup de chance nous de vivre dans
une démocratie il y a des atteintes au
droit de certains et de certaines il y a
des il y a des dérives il y a des
bêtises bon mais enfin ça n'a rien à
voir quand au présent turc vous savez
bien que c'était une blague qui
circulait pendant longtemps tu aimes les
prisons de Turcs elles sont connues pour
pas être bien pire que les nôtres je
pense et pourtant c'est pas que les
nôtres sont très dures mais et on va en
parler enfin ça n'a rien à voir allez je
vous propose maintenant de nous projeter
sur celui qui pourrait tomber faire
tomber
erloane on le surnomme le Gandhi turc
c'est un économiste reconnu et respecté
et il a réussi Stéphane blackowski nous
le disait a fédéré autour de lui si
différents partis portraits signés
Hélène Bonduelle
il a souvent Patti de l'image d'un homme
d'appareil sans charisme à 74 ans qui
est mal qui risque d'arroglou se voit
lui comme la force tranquille une force
au service d'un rêve rompre avec l'air
Erdogan et sauver la démocratie en
Turquie
je connais tous les problèmes de la
Turquie on les connaît tous et on va
tous les régler on a le savoir on a
l'expérience et on a la force cette
force est vous personne d'autre le
pouvoir c'est le peuple c'est vous
issu d'une famille modeste cette
économiste de formation lancée en
politique il y a 20 ans est à la tête du
CHP le parti républicain du peuple
depuis 2010
Kemal quérus daroglou c'est monsieur
tout le monde quand il se filme dans sa
cuisine parlant économie des vidéos qui
cartonnent sur les réseaux sociaux
notre vrai sujet c'est cet oignon
si Erdogan reste cet oignon sera vendu
sans livre turques aujourd'hui il est
déjà à 30 livres turques
c'est aussi monsieur anti corruption
monsieur justice comme cette marche de
240 km qui organise en 2017 pour
soutenir un député de son parti
incarcéré
cette marche est une marche de justice
qui compte veut la justice doit soutenir
cette marche il n'y a pas de justice
dans un pays où les prisons sont pleines
il n'y a pas d'état de droits dans un
pays où il n'y a pas de justice il n'y a
pas de paix dans un pays où il n'y a pas
de justice
lui qui signe chacun de ces meetings en
adressant à la foule ce geste en forme
de cœur a su séduire un électorat à plus
jeune
Erdogan doit partir pourquoi je voterai
pour le CHP parce que nous ne pouvons
pas gagner notre vie
notre jeunesse a disparu mon enfant a 3
ans et il réclame du pain et de la
nourriture mais nous ne pouvons pas lui
donner
que mal qui risque d'arroglou mise sur
une alliance de six parties d'opposition
pour conquérir le pouvoir mais le laïque
issu d'une branche minoritaire de
l'islam lavisme devra encore convaincre
dans une Turquie principalement sunnite
quel contraste c'est très impressionnant
le contraste entre les deux hommes il y
a deux Turquie qui s'affrontent là dans
cette élection il est calme il est posé
une insulte pas son adversaire et il se
dit l'héritier data turc le parti que a
fondé à tâture que il le dirige c'est ça
le CHP la minorité religieuse à vie
c'est très important il l'assume
complètement expliquez-nous en quoi
c'est important
c'est tradition cette minorité elle est
vie qui a été
marginalisée exclu parfois persécuté
malheureusement dans c'est une branche
de l'Islam c'est une branche de l'Islam
néo confrérie une vision une autre
perception de l'islam qui est beaucoup
plus c'est un critique beaucoup plus je
dirais un mélange de croyances
préhistamiques d'Islam on rupture avec
l'islam orthodoxie
orthodoxe classique les musulmans il est
musulmans c'est comme musulman mais un
instant particulier qui est beaucoup
plus je dirais une espèce de philosophie
qui a une certaine en fait il y a pas
une plante il y a des formes de allégé
en Turquie en gros ce qui fait la grande
différence entre c'est que pour eux
beaucoup plus que moi mais surtout la
figure de Ali qui est très importante
pour les croyances de alibi mais qui le
revendit qui leur permet d'envoyer un
signal aussi sur les minorités
auparavant elle doit y jouer sur le côté
sectaire c'est à dire qu'il instrumenté
ce côté confessionnaire professionnels
pour mettre en difficulté son adversaire
or là avant même qu'il ne le fasse et
c'était la grande force de closed c'est
qu'en fait il s'est présenté avec une
petite vidéo qui avait beaucoup de
succès pour dire je suis musulman et
aller vite ça c'est important et de ce
fait je dirais qu'il a réussi à couper
l'herbe sur le qui de ce fait n'a
pas pu instrumentaliser c'est identité
et ça donnait l'image de quelqu'un qui
respecte des minorité donc c'est un
nature c'est un atout et l'autre
différence c'est qu'en fait c'est que
justement ce qui paraissait comme une
faiblesse donc c'est devenu une force
c'est à dire que le manque de charisme
entre guillemets au contraire c'est
devenu le père tranquille
récupérer le grand-père qui va sauver
tout le monde et ça c'est la grande
parce que les Turcs n'en peuvent plus de
ce style un peu arrogant
des meetings je suis en train de crier
de qu'on va chez erdouane alors là il se
présente avec un autre style et qui
plaît justement
authentique démocrate on peut le dire il
y a pas de doute là-dessus là-dessus il
a pas il y a pas de doute et il est très
finalement il s'est avéré très très
habile parce que c'est pas un politicien
une bête politique comme elle doit il
n'avait pas l'art de parler il est
toujours pas comme lui mais ce qui fait
c'est des petits vidéos et en plus il
peut pas laisser exprimer dans les
médias mainstream maintenant lui donc il
fait des petites vidéos par thème là on
le voit souvent dans sa cuisine et qui
va droit au but quand on revient à la
vidéo allez-y qui est dans une autre
cadre en fait il a dit qu'il est allé
vivre mais il n'a pas du tout parlé de
la religion
il s'est adressé exclusivement aux
jeunes en disant moi je suis allévy je
suis née comme ça mais ça n'a aucune
importance quand vous allez y lire c'est
pas ma religion que vous allez y lire
mais ce que vous avez aimé c'est
quelqu'un d'honnête et moi je suis
honnête et il s'est adressé c'est ce
qu'il fait il ne s'adresse pas à toi il
s'adresse toujours à l'ensemble de la
population et parfois aux jeunes et
parce que l'électorat jeune a son
importance dans ses élections bien sûr
Vincent je voudrais qu'on essaye de
comprendre ce qui pourrait changer mais
évidemment beaucoup de conditionnel d'un
point de vue géopolitique notamment
vis-à-vis de la Russie vis-à-vis des
questions de sécurité vis-à-vis de
l'OTAN vis-à-vis de l'Occident en
général de l'Union européenne si c'est
cet homme qui risque d'être blue je
tente de son nom qui l'emportait si l'on
s'en tient au catéchisme de son
entourage sur les enjeux géopolitiques
il affirme la vocation
occidentale de la Turquie ce qui ne va
pas nécessairement de soi
passage il donne aussi tes gages à
l'électorat traditionnel quand même à
l'origine une proposition de loi qui
garantirait aux femmes le droit de
porter le foulard dans l'espace public
ou l'université je ferme ma parenthèse
il parle de l'Europe avec des accents un
peu moins anatomiques que
erdoan par moment cela dit sur deux
grands enjeux
les différences sont relativement
symboliques alors sur la Russie il y a
une sorte de consensus sur la nécessité
d'avoir ce qu'il appelle une relation
équilibrée on ne sort de l'ambiguïté
qu'à ses dépenses c'est bien connu sur
la Syrie en revanche nous en parlions
antenne tout à l'heure il est un peu
plus volontariste dans la volonté
précisément de sceller une
réconciliation avec le régime de Bachar
al-Assad dont on voit contre toute
morale d'ailleurs que c'est le cas
autour de la Ligue arabe aujourd'hui
mais
c'est à la fois lié au fardeau des trois
millions quatre cent mille réfugiés
syriens qui se trouve sur le sol turc
qui est aussi la possibilité avoir une
main d'oeuvre à ville prix mais et puis
peut-être aussi peut-être aussi par
justement la Lévis qui a un cousin
syrien qui est lalaouisme c'est-à-dire
le régime minoritaire de bachar-assad
peut-être aussi moins de divergences
idéologique que erdoine pouvait en avoir
avec Bacha mais moi personnellement en
tout cas je parle que le contrôle de
gens dont l'expertise est plus affûté
que la mienne dans la matière je ne
pense pas qu'il y aura de
bouleversements géopolitiques sous une
éventuelle une hypothétique présidente
la manière de changer parce que
actuellement ce qui fait à toi c'est une
c'est une diplomatie transactionnelle
comme on appelle dans le jargon c'est à
dire en gros qui je donne ça tu me
donnes ça la donne
pour dans parfois
avec des contradictions un coup il est
allié avec la Russie parce que j'ai
jamais dans le long terme là on va
revenir je reviens toujours à cette
c'est la diplomatie turque qui va
vraiment intervenir pas telle ou telle
personne pas le Président c'est quelque
chose institutionnaliser et ça va
changer beaucoup par rapport à l'Europe
ou à d'autres c'est la manière est très
important je voudrais qu'on termine avec
avec cette question et ce et ce tweet de
de d'ardoise il a fait ce matin il dit
nous ne laisserons pas jeter de l'ombre
sur notre démocratie s'il le faut nous
protégerons notre indépendance et notre
avenir au prix de nos vies renvoyant au
coup d'état qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ce tweet ne veut rien de bon si le père
alors depuis ce matin il y a beaucoup de
débats beaucoup de discussions
personnellement je j'ai beaucoup échangé
avec des collègues qui sont à l'heure
actuelle en Turquie par rapport à ce
tweet c'est qu'en fait c'est un truc qui
fait peur qui donne le sentiment qui ne
veut pas reconnaître les les choix des
urnes mais en même temps j'ai
l'impression en fait que c'est aussi il
y a une partie de cette huit qui a été
coupée ça aussi je pense qu'il faut il
faut être
ceux qui l'ont diffusé c'est à dire que
il y a une partie de cette Twitter qui a
été qui a été diffusée mais ils sont là
dans son contexte c'est tout à fait le
discours habituel de eldouane qui est
très vindicatif qui je suis les
sentiments sur le patriotisme mais c'est
vrai que ça donne le sentiment qui aura
pas de reconnaissance de de du choix des
urnes mais au final je pense que et ça a
été dit par notre collègue tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en fait connaissance le
peuple Turquie est très attaché à
l'addition des urnes à la tradition
démocratique c'est que il sera obligé de
reconnaître le choix des zones il pourra
pas faire autrement et espère que votre
lecture et votre optimisme voilà frappe
qu'est-ce qui va se passer c'est est-ce
que on n'a pas du tout l'habitude ça
c'est l'armée et la police vont
intervenir contre le peuple qui a voté
on n'a pas eu en sentant d'histoire
c'est une inconnue si jamais il
réagissait on va suivre ça forcément ce
week-end et voilà
allez voter les Turcs merci à vous merci
d'être venu débattre sur ce plateau vous
restez évidemment avec moi Dominique
Simone Simonneau dans une grosse dizaine
de minutes les partis pris de nos alors
beaucoup de mots à la une ce soir
d'abord les nouveaux mots du dico
auscultés par Maître Bertrand Perrier et
puis le mot de la semaine de la
sémiologue Mariette d'arrêt grance le
mot narratif et puis enfin dans Bourbon
express avec Stéphanie Despierres gros
coup de gueule du groupe communiste qui
a même écrit à la première ministre on
verra pourquoi mais d'abord on va se
pencher sur votre rapport Dominique
Simoneau manifestement rien ne change
dans les lieux de privation de liberté
on voit cela d'abord dans l'invitation
de Marco pommier et on en parle ensemble
juste après si on vous invite Dominique
Simonneau c'est parce qu'une nouvelle
fois vous dressez un sombre tableau de
nos prisons françaises rien ne change et
le ton est donné dès le début de votre
rapport avec une définition de l'inertie
inertie manque d'activité d'énergie état
de ce qui ne bouge pas ou peu synonyme
apathie immobilisme inaction facilité
Dominique Simoneau vous connaissez de
l'Intérieur l'univers carcéral mieux que
quiconque vous qui avez travaillé
pendant 12 au tribunal de Nanterre comme
éducatrice en prison puis comme
contrôleuse d'anciens détenus en liberté
conditionnelle vous l'ancienne
journaliste spécialiste des affaires
judiciaires à Libération ou encore au
Canard Enchaîné aujourd'hui contrôle le
général des lieux de privation de
liberté votre rôle c'est de vérifier que
les droits fondamentaux des personnes
enfermées soient respectées mais ça
revient c'est vrai à défendre les droits
de gens dont personne n'a rien à faire
ou pire que tout le monde déteste
c'est-à-dire les déviants et on dirait
que ces droits là c'est pas grave si on
les respecte pas dans votre dernier
rapport annuel vous alerter sur ces
prisons qui débordent plus de 73000
détenus pour 60000 places le mois
dernier un record dans certaines maisons
d'arrêt le constat est alarmant jusqu'à
trois détenus dans une cellule 21h sur
24 moins d'un mètre carré par personne
une surpopulation aux conséquences
délétères violence manque d’hygiène
difficile accès aux soins et aux
activités sans oublier la vétusté des
cellules les appels à l'aide se
multiplient certains sont grignotés par
les punaises envahies par les cafards et
les rats vous dénoncez aussi l'état
déplorable des hôpitaux psychiatriques
de nos centres éducatifs pour mineurs ou
encore des centres de rétention
administratives pour étrangers ou
certains enfants se retrouvent parfois
sans jouer alors Dominique Simoneau le
gouvernement a pour ambition de créer
15000 places de prison d'ici 2027 mais
peut-on y croire doutez vous de la
volonté politique
les conditions des détenus s'il fallait
noter la France de 1 à 10 où on est
exactement vous qui pouvez contrôler
sans prévenir tous ces lieux-là oui
alors il y a pas que les prisons mais en
tout cas mais sur la prison je mettrai
une très mauvaise note je saurais pas
vous dire combien sur votre échelle mais
c'est une très mauvaise note et mais on
parlait démocratie mais ça n'a rien à
voir bien sûr on est d'accord alors
est-ce qu'on peut quand même faire
avancer les choses parce que on entend
ça fait quoi des décennies la
spéculation carcérale ça fait décennies
qu'on parle de vétusté des moïsecuité
d'exécuter des cellules et puis il y a
eu le covid et là
total changement régulation un grand bol
d'air pour les personnels on n'a pas su
tirer les leçons de la absolument pas
je pense que c'est un calcul politique
parce que le Président de la République
en 2008 il prononce un très beau
discours 2008 2018 il prononce un très
beau discours à l'école de
l'administration pénitentiaire dans
laquelle il dit qu'il veut voir sortir
tous ceux qui en prison non rien à y
faire et je prendrai l'exemple des plus
de 30 % de gens atteints de troubles
psychiatriques graves en prison 30%
c'est énorme ça existe sur monstrueux et
donc poursuivez et il a dit je veux voir
se développer des expériences de
régulation carcérale et puis il a
abandonné parce que c'est politiquement
il n'arrive pas à porter cette parole
parce qu'avec le covid on a très vite
compris qu'on y arriverait pas et donc
les détenus en maison d'arrêts en fin de
peine ou pour des courtes peines sont
sortis exactement et je rappelle fallait
continuer ça mais bien sûr parce que
c'est des gens qui sont sortis à quoi 15
jours trois semaines un mois de leur
femme peine ça n'est pas un drame je
pense et d'ailleurs il n'y a pas eu de
drame du votre vie délibération du covid
on s'est retrouvé avec 58 800
prisonniers et de fait toutes les
détentions tout le monde nous le disait
ça va beaucoup mieux on respire enfin
les gens peuvent avoir accès aux soins
ils pour avoir accès aux actifs pourquoi
tous les acteurs ne se sont pas réunis à
ce moment-là alors qui s'est passé parce
que peut-être tout le monde a cru que on
allait continuer sur cette sur cette
ligne
pleine d'espoir et je dis pleine
d'espoir pas seulement pour les détenus
ou leurs familles plein d'espoir pour
toute la société parce que plus les gens
vont sortir avec des voix de réinsertion
plus ont appris des choses en prison
plus auront un métier à lire et à écrire
parce qu'il y a 17% d'illettrés en
prison je sais pas qu'il soit formé à
quelque chose qui s'est participé à des
activités ludiques ou pas
dans un meilleur état il sortira mieux
il se conduira à la sortie c'est connu
alors la catastrophe en prison vous vous
en parlez pour les détenus pour les
conditions des tensions elle s'étend au
surveillant et là le rapport il est il
est alarmant parce que un surveillant
pour 100 détenus ça ressemble à quoi au
quotidien pareil c'était pour un table
et sont les surveillants moi c'est pour
ça que dans le rapport j'explique que il
y a un immense abandon de l'État à la
fois des détenus mais aussi des
surveillants et de tous les lieux
d'enfermement d'ailleurs parce que sont
tous des gens que vous repassez cet
extrait de ce que j'avais dit dont
personne n'a rien à faire au fond donc
politiquement c'est pas porteur de
porter cette parole des détenus c'est le
comportement on a un garde des sceaux
qui s'appelle Rick Dupond-Moretti ancien
avocat s'y attaché à cette cause là je
le regrette parce que je l'ai tellement
entendu plaider avec sa fougue son brio
son intelligence
les conditions épouvantables de
attention que c'est vrai que je
m'attendais à autre chose maintenant
qu'il est là et c'est hors la France n'a
jamais compté autant de détenus alors il
y a les mauvais élèves Bois-d'Arcy dans
les Yvelines Bordeaux Draguignan le
tableau n'est pas complètement noir on a
rénové la santé rénover elle est très
mais elle est pleine 90%
non non c'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
non freine mais il y a même des gens
dans la pénitentiaire qui vous disent
freine il faudra le raser on sait plus
quoi faire là-dedans aujourd'hui il y a
encore aussi des personnes en prison qui
n'ont rien à y faire parce que vous
l'évoquez ils ont des des problèmes
psychiatriques et là il devrait aller à
l'hôpital mais l'hôpital psychiatrique
c'est l'urgence absolue plus personne ne
veut y travailler c'est-à-dire que nous
on traverse des services fermés
puisqu'on est chargé de vérifier les
droits des gens placés en soins sans
consentement sont respectés à travers
des services où il manque 30 40% de
soignants de médecins d'infirmiers vous
rendez compte donc forcément ça
rejaillit sur la prise en charge des
patients qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit au
ministère de la Santé tout à l'heure
vous disiez 30% des prisonniers sont
atteints de troubles graves c'est un
chiffre énorme il devrait être soigné en
hôpital psychiatrique on n'a pas les
personnels qu'est-ce qu'on répond à
cette impasse là nous répond que ce que
vous voulez les médecins veulent plus
être psychiatre
nous on dit oui mais faites en sorte
qu'ils aient envie de l'être avant
c'était une matière noble la psychiatrie
faites en sorte que ça le redevienne
créer des filières faites des appels
d'air et le plus grave c'est la
pédopsychiatrie la pédopsychiatrie les
enfants oui parce que ce sont des
enfants sont des enfants donc comme il y
a des territoires entiers dépourvus de
services de pédopsychiatrie et même de
pédopsychiatre ça veut dire que ces
troubles si un enfant a des troubles on
ne détecte pas on ne les soigne pas on
ne les prend pas en charge et donc ils
montent en puissance et après on les
retrouve placés par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ou dans des foyers vous tenez
à ce mot d'enfant et pas de mineur parce
que vous dites gamin vous dites enfant
vous dites jamais mineur pourquoi ça
renvoie
un truc c'est que quand on dit mineur ça
veut forcément dire enfant enfermé ça
veut dire enfant dangereux en fait et
donc ça a commencé à me dégoûter ce mot
je dis Goose gamin enfant ce que je
trouve ça dingue d'appeler des gens des
mineurs ça fait c'est très administratif
pas ça non alors
vous pointez d'autres responsabilités
les magistrats vous trouvez que ils ont
tendance à facilement
ils expliquent très bien que c'est plus
facile les audiences de comparution
immédiate c'est cette justice ultra
rapide
sais pas pourquoi il aime pas les
ministres de l'Intérieur je crois que
c'est c'est une sorte de rituel avec le
contrôleur oui des lieux de privation de
liberté c'est intéressant parce que
quand vous êtes arrivé comme contrôleur
vous avez très bien dit je suis surprise
je ne comprends pas pourquoi Emmanuel
Macron m'a nommé vous êtes franchement
l'emmerdeuse quelque part l'empêcheuse
de tourner en rond on connaissait vos
articles dans Libération sans concession
alors est-ce que vous avez compris
pourquoi il vous a nommé depuis non je
l'avais prévenu j'ai dit vous aurez que
des emmerdes avec moi il m'a dit
pourquoi j'ai dit parce que je dis ce
que je pense il m'a dit c'est ce que je
vous demande alors moi maintenant je lui
demande puisque maintenant je vous dis
ce que je pense essayer de changer les
choses et
c'est meilleur pour la société tout
entière si tout ça va mieux c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre et c'est ce
discours qu'il devrait porter et ben
voilà l'appel est lancée et on espère
vous retrouver l'année prochaine avec un
rapport et quelques raisons d'espérer
bien merci Dominique Simonneau vous
restez avec moi pour la dernière partie
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis leur parti pris vous vous
faire réagir on les accueille tout de
suite bienvenue
[Musique]
Bertrand Périer maître Perrier qui va
regarder ses nouveaux mots en bon
français dans notre dictionnaire et
Mariette darrigan notre sémiologue sur
le mot de la semaine bienvenue à tous
les deux on commence comme chaque soir
par le bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nationale nous est
racontée ce soir par Stéphanie Despierre
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir et c'est
l'histoire d'un coup de colère celui à
d'andréchassaigne le président du groupe
communiste député depuis 2002 connu pour
sa moustache et sa voix grave qui donne
souvent dans l'hémicycle alors cette
fois il a pris la plume pour dénoncer la
manière dont ce sont déroulés les débats
jeudi dernier lors de l'examen d'un
texte des communistes d'une proposition
de loi mercredi il a carrément écrit à
la première ministre Elisabeth borne
votre gouvernement écrit-il c'est livré
au jeu de l'obstruction alors dans le
viseur d'André Chasset il y a deux
ministres celui de l'économie Bruno Le
Maire et celui des comptes publics
Gabriel Attal André Chassagny écrit ils
ont donné un spectacle indigne même un
spectacle de music hall
inutile plus loin les deux ministres ont
pas labré pendant plus d'une heure dans
l'hémicycle pour empêcher la discussion
selon André Chassaigne ils ont empêché
les députés d'aller jusqu'au votes de
cette proposition de loi et alors dans
sa lettre il enfonce le clou et il
s'adresse à Elisabeth borne c'est inédit
cela en dit long sur le sens que votre
gouvernement donne à l'apaisement que
vous vous êtes fixé c'est clair en fait
ce soir là il y a rien les communistes
défendaient l'idée d'indexer la DGF la
dotation de l'État aux collectivité
locale sur l'inflation les ministres s'y
mettent à deux pour expliquer que cela
coûte très cher le temps fil André
chassaseigne et ses députés
s'impatientent et s'agitent
vous laissez le ministre se terminer son
propos c'est pas la peine durer
chers collègues
ce n'est pas la peine d'hurler on écoute
monsieur Attal
allez-y monsieur le ministre
alors on a chronométré les deux
ministres ont parlé 54 minutes pas plus
d'une heure c'est conséquent certes pour
un débat sur une seule proposition de
loi sur une journée en plus dédiée à
l'opposition ça peut en effet paraître
beaucoup moins il y a quand même
quelques milliards d'euros en jeu en
revanche vous allez le voir plus la
séance avance plus les communistes
s'énervent plus le discours de Gabriel
Attal n'en finit plus de finir et ça
n'est pas comme vous le faites en
cherchant à nous empêcher de dialoguer à
empêcher le gouvernement de s'exprimer
de rendre des comptes devant cette
assemblée sur l'action qui est mené nous
sommes fiers de cette action nous
assumons l'action qui est la nôtre au
service des collectivités territoriales
au service des Français au service de
notre pays et combien même vous cherchez
à nous intimider nous continuerons à
vous tendre la main pour travailler
ensemble au service des Français
alors déjà cet hiver pendant les débats
sur la réforme des retraites le camp
présidentiel et l'opposition de gauche
c'était mutuellement accusé de faire de
l'obstruction bah en fait ça continue
constatons votre absence de majorité
vous avez eu un comportement pitoyable
on avait cru comprendre dans le
règlement intérieur que vous aviez
utilisé toutes les ficelles 47 ans
procédure accélérée recours massif aux
ordonnances 49-3 ce soir vous venez
d'inventer pour refuser de répondre à la
réalité des collectivités territoriales
la diarrhée verbale ministériel
pitoyable monsieur Attal
finalement il n'y a pas eu de vote
finale jeudi dernier la séance sur ses
niches là je vous le rappelle se termine
à minuit et cette fois-ci c'est aussi en
partie car la séance est terminée encore
plus tôt que prévue à cause du malaise
d'une fonctionnaire en fait Myriam ce
coup de gueule des communistes est
annonciateur de la prochaine grosse
bataille du Parlement ce sera le 8 juin
lors d'une autre niche parlementaire
celle du groupe IOT cette fois les
centrices et indépendants veulent
purement et simplement faire abroger la
réforme des retraites alors ce sera un
moment à haut risque pour les troupes
macronistes alors cette lettre c'est
aussi une manière pour la gauche
communiste de mettre en garde contre
toute tentative d'obstruction ce jour-là
qu'elle vienne des députés Renaissance
ou du gouvernement parce que l'horloge
dans une niche une proposition d'Oise
c'est essentielle parce que si c'est pas
voté à minuit c'est terminé vous
regardez un peu les débats
parlementaires est-ce qu'elle vous
réjouit cette nouvelle Assemblée si
particulière où est-ce qu'elle vous
déçoit
Joker allez
en général on comprend ce que ça veut
dire les jokers bon on enchaîne avec
vous Bertrand vous voulez revenir sur
ces nouveaux mots qui vont intégrer les
éditions du Larousse et du Robert en
2024 l'année prochaine et oui Myriam
alors si je vous dis par exemple que
sans vouloir vous spoiler je suis en PLS
car mon crush m'a gosté et que c'est
malaisant et bien vous avez reconnu
quelques-uns des nouveaux mots du
dictionnaire 150 nouveaux mots nouveaux
mots pour un nouveau monde qui ont été
sélectionnés donc par des lexicographes
qui partout mettent leurs antennes pour
détecter les nouveaux mots les nouveaux
usages des mots et qui sélectionnent
ceux qui leur paraissent être les plus
fréquents et les plus pérennes avec
évidemment une petite différence
d'ailleurs entre Larousse et Robert on
considère généralement que le Robert est
un peu plus en avance que le Larousse
notamment il y avait eu un débat sur
Yelle le pronom neutre qui est dans le
Robert mais pas dans le Larousse que dit
cette nouvelle moisson elle dit les
reflets de notre société elle dit les
mouvements de d'abord on a covidé et
co-anxiété localisme vélo russion
complot sphère la sphère complotiste
mais j'en ai donné à quelqu'un un genre
qui n'est pas le sien Nasser dans les
manifestations boboïsées ça c'est un peu
les mouvements de société il y a aussi
les mouvements des entreprises du
travail greenwashing webinaire ou Flex
office home stageing je sais Mariette
que tout ça vous réjouit formidablement
et puis il y a les mots aussi des
nouvelles technologies il y a
instagrammable enfin instagramable qui
vient dans le dictionnaire on va pouvoir
photographier nos plats qui sont
instagramables metavèrent ou mixtape
alors à chaque fois qu'il y a des
nouveaux mots on en dira un mot
justement Mariette il y a des polémiques
attention on est en train de faire
décliner notre belle langue trop
d'anglissimes c'est trop relâché c'est
trop vulgaire qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez alors il faut quand même garder à
l'esprit une chose c'est que le
dictionnaire c'est la langue telle
qu'elle est et pas la langue telle qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit le dictionnaire
enregistre nos usages des mots il ne
crée pas de mots et il n’approuve pas de
mots donc à supposer qu'il y a un
affaiblissement de la langue le
dictionnaire n'en est pas responsable et
c'est à chacun de nous qu'il revient de
de surveiller son usage des mots ces
petites paresses ces petits mimétisme
ces petites facilités qui font que
peut-être parfois on emploie des mots
qui ne sont pas très justes mais il faut
dire une chose c'est que imputer au
dictionnaire le déclin de la langue
c'est vraiment confondre le symptôme et
la maladie enfin c'est quand même un peu
une consécration non que d'entrer pour
un mot après au dictionnaire ça veut
dire que l'usage est fréquent et reconnu
comme tel mais la langue est évidemment
un corps vivant qui évolue au gré des
usages et les nouveaux mots sont un peu
le symbole de ces évolutions de la
société alors il y a évidemment un grand
problème qui est l'anglicisme et là le
Larousse a donné pour les nouveaux mots
anglais des équivalents donc plutôt que
Flex office dite bureau nomade plutôt
que webinaire dit séminaire en ligne et
plutôt que escape dites jeux d'évasion
donc le dictionnaire c'est pas un blanc
sain c'est pas une carte blanche pour
utiliser ces mots là c'est un constat
qu'ils existent donc il faut que chacun
garde dans la langue aussi sont
l'élégance et sa dignité un peu comme
Charles III qui lui est entré à la
rubrique des noms propres merci beaucoup
pour cette carte blanche bien enlevée
comme on l'aime là-dessus vous savourez
tous ces nouveaux mots ou vous regardez
ça ensemble sourcils Mariette non mais
c'est toujours intéressant c'est une
forme d'actualité je suis d'accord avec
Bertrand c'est très sociologique ça
reflète qui nous sommes et
l'américanisation de notre langage elle
est là bien sûr un autre mot qui fait
l'actualité et que vous avez choisi
cette semaine Mariette c'est le mot
narratif pourquoi c'est ça vous savez
qu'on dit beaucoup le narratif de
Poutine ou le narratif du gouvernement
le narratif des syndicats qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce mot alors il se donne comme
de l'anglais la traduction d'un concept
qui serait venu des spin docteurs
américains mais en fait c'est du
français c'est du latin c'est du
français les Français ont inventé ce
concept dans les années 70 et
théoriciens de la littérature très
important parce qu'ils ont déconstruit
des récits ils ont expliqué comment ça a
marché ils ont inventé la narratologie
et donc ils nous ont expliqué comment je
sais pas il y a des l'Odyssée les
Chevaliers de la Table Ronde comment ça
héroïsait la vie et comment ça faisait
si vous voulez la vie en grand avec les
risques que ça comporte c'est bien ça
plutôt non oui c'est bien dans les
livres dans les films au ciné c'est plus
problématique quand ça vient dans la
politique alors nous sommes une espèce
fabulatrice selon la formule très jolie
de Nancy Houston la romancière on a
besoin l'être humain a besoin de ce
récit oui exactement il a besoin de
récit mais il faut regarder quelque
chose en face par rapport à ce besoin
c'est aussi souvent un besoin de sang un
besoin de vraiment de combat très big
girls and life là pour le coup vraiment
c'est plus grand que moi et donc je vais
m'identifier à des choses qui sont très
souvent guerrières Lilia c'est quand
même la mort en technicolores il faut
pas oublier ça alors en ce moment ce mot
de narratif il est beaucoup chez les
experts militaires qui commentent la
guerre en Ukraine c'est vrai il y a sa
place parce qu'il y a en effet une
guerre aussi des récits on le comprend
bien mais la question pour nous je pense
c'est est-ce que cette ce narrative
guerrier ce concept-là doit venir dans
la politique domestique il est très
présent c'est vrai dans la politique
d'un ministre d'un président
extrême droite parle d'un narratif le
grand remplacement exactement alors par
exemple voilà c'est un très bon exemple
nous avons le grand remplacement qui est
un narratif ou la bataille des pauvres
contre les riches ou les riches contre
les pauvres même une certaine écologie
parfois alors plus le titre est grand
justement et plus la réflexion est
petite il y a un effet de vaste
communicant c'est ça je trouve qu'il
nous pose qui nous pose problème alors
le narratif avec ses gros sabots il
empêche le délibératif l'argumentatif
l'imaginatif de conclure alors justement
on le garde il y a quand même un peu
d'imagination dans ces narratifs bah ce
qui pose le vrai problème c'est mon
troisième grief contre ce mot c'est
qu'il nous transforme en passif
justement en écoutant en consommateur de
fiction et d'ailleurs c'est pas un
hasard si on sent les jeux vidéos qui
utilisent le plus les narratifs mais la
politique Myriam vous le savez mieux que
moi c'est ni narratif ni ludique la
politique ce sont des actes c'est pas
que des paroles et donc tu réussis du
narratif merci beaucoup merci Dominique
simeno rendez-vous allez l'année
prochaine ou sur un débat parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de prison vous savez ici
à l'Assemblée nationale merci les
affranchis merci Stéphanie c'est le
week-end profitez bien à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]